here's something you probably did not
expect to hear arguably ever a sitting
congressman wants the President of the
United States investigated for
threatening an American state
specifically Donald Trump's threat to
the state of Alaska we're now learning
more about the nature of the threats
that were issued by the Interior
Secretary Ryan's Enki to Alaska senators
Lisa Murkowski and Dan Sullivan last
week this was all related to the
Obamacare repeal boat Lisa Murkowski
ultimately voted against Obamacare
repeal and we've heard from Dan Sullivan
the other senator Republican senator
from Alaska about the nature of the
threats that were received and Dan
Sullivan said I'm not going to go into
the details but I fear that the strong
economic growth Pro Energy Pro mining
Pro jobs and personnel from Atlanta from
Alaska
who are part of those policies are going
to stop I tried to push back on behalf
of all Alaskans we're facing some
difficult times and there's a lot of
enthusiasm for the policies that
secretary Zinke and the president had
been talking about with regard to our
economy but the message was pretty clear
the idea being that federal aid was
being threatened Raul Grijalva who's the
senior Democrat on the House of
Representatives Committee on Natural
Resources says he is asking the
Government Accountability Office to
investigate to investigate the
allegations against the Interior
Secretary threatening to punish your
rivals as political blackmail is
something that we would see from it's
going to sound kind of weird from the
Kremlin in Russia secretaries inky's
willingness to deliver these threats
says a lot about the sort of ethical and
moral standards that we're seeing from
this administration and Rachel Maddow
pointed this out late last week people
went to jail for Bridgegate right that
was where Republican New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie and his allies really
were involved in shutting down lanes on
the George Washington Bridge
and that actually led that was for
political retribution in 2013 and it led
to the death of a woman who needed an
ambulance two people went to prison for
that this is threatening an entire state
aid over a Senate vote it does sound to
me like Trump and zinc ease threats
completely backfired here not only
because you might have investigations or
even indictment I'm out of this but also
because the Obama care vote repeal vote
failed miserably and Murkowski was put
into a position where she had to vote no
on those because otherwise it would look
as if she was bullied into just
accepting whatever Trump was saying
right if she had to stand up for herself
to not look weak if this if the news of
this threat leaked it despite her voting
no it's very likely it would have leaked
if she had voted yes and then she would
have had to explain wait a second you
were a no for a while you get this
threat and then now you vote yes and I'm
backed out that's a whole new set of
problems and I want to be really clear
the follow-through as to whether they
actually do anything to Alaska's federal
aid it doesn't matter it's like when
Trump jr. met with the Russian lawyer in
Trump Tower whether or not he got the
dirt on Hillary Clinton is not relevant
what matters is did he intend to collude
and receive things of value from a
foreign hostile power the threat here to
her Alaska is the scandal and in the
midst of all the other scandals this is
barely registered like we did a story
last week Pat and it got about 62,000
views on YouTube there's so much else
going on that the president threatening
one of the 50 states of the United
States of America is not even making the
news that it warrants I mean there's
just so much news and we couldn't
possibly cover all of it especially
because you know of course the scandals
but you want to focus on the issues that
really impact Americans day to day and
destroy some things just have to get
filtered out Alaska is currently seeking
federal permission to expand oil
drilling in the National Petroleum
Reserve and there are fears that the
White House might block that as
retribution is that a possible silver
lining like maybe despite a completely
ridiculous and capricious threat against
the state of Alaska they might prevent
Alaska from doing more drilling that
would be bad for the environment have I
found some amount of a silver lining
here
I don't know and let's remember that
Trump won Alaska - it's not like Chris
Christie trying to get retribution on
the counties that he lost in New Jersey
it's very weird it's
very very weird and I hope that there is
an investigation I support congressman
Grijalva skål för one